how is the game changed for
screenwriters to break into the business
say from 20 years prior or is everything
still the same the fundamentals are
still the same I would say that the
fundamentals are to sit now yeah there
are some specific differences but
fundamentally it has always been quote
impossible to break in as a screenwriter
it's because how many films are made a
year mainstream Hollywood make maybe 300
and 500 films a year and it's going down
it's actually since the recession of oh
wait it's gotten worse one of the
specific ways that it has changed for
the worse is the fact that since that
time development money has essentially
disappeared nobody wants to develop
anymore now used to be the writer could
make a living could sustain themselves
and therefore continue to practice the
craft and getting better through just
development work they have a good script
maybe it gets optioned a few times it's
a calling card for them to get work for
hire that's now much more difficult one
of the things that I always have a big
problem with is these pitch festivals
because they promise people oh you're
going to pitch to these executives and
maybe of course everybody thinks the
other but that would be me get the deal
well this is absurd
it doesn't happen since away not even
the top screenwriters are getting deals
off of pitches because there's no
development money it's all about it's
either on the page in a script or it
doesn't exist right oh that sounds like
a great idea let me see the script
and especially if you're not one of the
20 or so top work and screenwriters
you're not going to get a deal with the
pitch they don't even know if you can
write a script or not
so these unfortunately are some of the
negatives that have become more negative
over the years now on the other side and
against something that really hasn't
changed it's all about is it on the page
one of the advantage that we have as
writers over actors is that we don't
have to what dishing in-person right
they don't have to reject us personally
right it can be on the page I can be
writing on Mars if it's on the page
I don't care where you're from I don't
care what you look like right if it's on
the page and it's a good script and this
is another reason why it's so important
to prove yourself on the page to prove
that you've got the craft and I always
tell writers if you have a script that
is rejected it isn't necessarily reject
it because the quality of writing wasn't
there most of the time it is rejected
because that producer didn't simply
didn't like that story idea didn't feel
that it was a commercial idea for what
they wanted to try to sell you can't get
as the writer you can't have any control
over that the only thing you have
control over is the quality of writing
on the page if you do your job
and master the craft so that you get
that quality on the page at some point
you will break through I true I believe
that 20 years ago I believe it now and
again for most writers they think that
they've done that craft work and they
really haven't so should people set
aside a fund for
pitchfest or avoid them entirely I
personally think that it's a waste of
money
and I would have went entirely the one
possible advantage that you can get
there is that someone will who has heard
your pitch will agree to read the script
but again it's very important for
writers to understand when you go to a
pitch festival it's not about selling
that idea you will not sell that idea
it's all about getting the door open so
that they will read your script because
most people when they go to these Phish
festivals don't have an agent so they
can't get send their script in but that
means that before you go to any pitch
festival you better have a great script
that you have written so that when the
person says mmm I like that idea I'd
like to see what at what you have that
you have a script to give them that will
show off your work as a writer because
the only thing that matters is a
completed script with the qualities on a
page should someone be worried that
someone might steal their idea no that's
the most overrated fear of writers
nobody cares about that it's too much
work to go from an idea to a really good
script for anybody now do do ideas get
stolen yes they do but most of the time
they're ideas that are in the air that
you know people grab that and different
people come up with them at different
times but again this emphasis on ideas
and the idea that you could sell an idea
now I'd just be an idea man and I'll
make a really nice living selling the
story ideas is total nonsense
you